[Music]
Megan is turning 37 tomorrow is her
first birthday as an official member of
the royal family and so Megan our gift
to you a Friday flashback to your very
interesting Hollywood past she's nearly
eleven weeks of duchess and at every
event the new HRH has been poised
elegant and very very royal she's come a
long way since her days as an actress
where she played everything from a
federal agent a fashion photographer
that's why you're not painted and even a
murderer you can't prove that I killed
Amy or Christina I'll be okay when I get
the Dutchess of Sussex kicked some butt
as an MMA fighter at the enemy's range
so are you Megan took on a wide spectrum
of roles when starting her career do you
want to buy me a drink on an episode of
castle she was a sleeping beauty with a
tiara atop her head
one of her very first jobs was on the
soap General Hospital I had this chart
right here dr. Lambert I don't see it a
notation anywhere
she had an in her father was the daytime
dramas lighting director oh my god I
totally forgot she was on I remember her
she's a lovely lovely woman a lovely
woman so cool she also showed off her
comedic chops uh-huh who are you
thinking about dad this bedroom scene is
from the sitcom the war at home who's in
the mood to go again
twice in one night check you most of her
work was on television sometimes just
meet someone and I just know I don't
know I guess it just seemed like nothing
ever did was good enough
some big screen rolls came her way but
only in small parts like a FedEx girl in
Horrible Bosses a bartenders serving
Robert Pattinson and remember me and as
Ashton Kutcher seatmate and a lot like
Love New York
after years of minor roles in 2011
Meagan scored her biggest gig to date as
a series regular on suits I'm Rachel
Zane I'll be giving your orientation wow
you're pretty the show made her in
demand on red carpets at the 2014 Super
Bowl she took part in a celebrity beach
volleyball game with PAL Serena Williams
she told Kevin just how competitive she
was so I am going to do my best to keep
up I'm a runner so I'm just hoping that
I can I see your aggressive face your
scary football face
[Applause]
you